[Musique]
alors avez vous un téléphone portable
ok pouvez vous me le montrer s'il vous
plaît aa je vois
vous avez donc une partie du congo entre
les mains je suis né en république
démocratique du congo plus communément
appelée rdc au congo
c'est un pays immense dont la superficie
est équivalente à 4 fois celle de la
france c'est un pays magnifique où il y
à vingt-deux mille ans
la première calculatrice a été inventée
aïcha go et plus récemment le vaccin
contre le virus ebola a été découvert
par un professeur congolais le congo est
aussi connu comme le deuxième poumon de
la terre car il abrite la deuxième forêt
tropicale la plus grande au monde dont
la végétation permet de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
il est entouré par le majestueux fleuve
congo le deuxième au monde par son débit
alors la créativité des congolais et
leur expression se manifeste à travers
l'art
la danse la musique et la mode et le
congo est un trésor naturel qui regorge
de terre innombrables et de minerais
précieux comme l'or le diamant le cobalt
le coltan l'uranium le lithium le cuivre
dont la plupart entre dans la
fabrication de nos téléphones portables
mais ce qu'on vaut que j'aime tant est
aussi un paradoxe car malgré toutes ses
richesses naturelles et intellectuelle
la majorité de ces 85 millions
d'habitants vit avec moins de un dollar
par jour
j'ai eu la chance de grandir dans une
famille qui a beaucoup voyagé et donc à
l'âge de 7 ans nous sommes allés voir
mon oncle qui était professeur en génie
électrique au canada et mon oncle à 20h
qui s'appelait kochka et un jour le chat
est descendu à la cave et moi j'ai suivi
le chat et quand j'ai allumé la lumière
de la cave
la salle était remplie d'ordinateur que
mon oncle était en train de fabriquer
j'ai fait moi j'étais fasciné alors
c'était là ma première rencontre avec
les systèmes vous dit sûrement mais
c'est quoi au juste des ce thème alors
c'est un acronyme pour sa science
technology engineering et maaf alors les
sciences ce sont l'ensemble des
connaissances relatives à des phénomènes
observés ou qui sont vérifiables par les
méthodes expérimentales la technologie
c'est l'ensemble des outils et des
matériaux qui interviennent dans
l'artisanat et dans l'industrie
quant à l'ingénierie c'est l'étude d'un
projet industriel sous tous ses aspects
et qui nécessite un travail d'équipé
espère alors quant au match je suis sûr
que vous en avez sans doute tous fait
bref par hasard à 7 ans je découvre cet
univers de ce thème à l'âge de 12 ans ma
famille et moi nous décidons de rentrer
au congo à kikwit dans la ville natale
de mon père et kikwit est une belle
petite ville traversée par la rivière
kwilu on peut y voir les hippopotames
pendant que les enfants nagent dans la
rivière c'est une ville située à 400 km
de kinshasa la capitale
c
à peu près deux jours de route à ce
moment-là kikwit à une population de 200
mille habitants soit à peu près cinq
fois la population actuelle de mots en
rouge mais kikwit est une ville sans eau
courante ni électricité
alors qu'est ce que ça signifie ça veut
dire qu à kikwit
si vous voulez voir un film vous acheter
du carburant
vous prenez le carburant et le mettez
dans un groupe électrogène et démarrer
le groupe électrogène pas d'électricité
sans carburant à l'âge de 17 ans je
tombe gravement malade à kikwit
j'ai une appendicite aiguë et je dois
absolument aller sous cette opération en
cas d'urgence alors il y en a t'il parmi
vous qui ont déjà une appendicite
avez vous été opéré d'urgence et on a
pas mal hein vous comprendrez donc ma
douleur
malheureusement pour moi il n'y avait
pas de carburant il n'y avait pas
d'électricité à l'hôpital général de
kikwit et en plus il y avait pénurie de
carburant dans la ville c'est à dire
qu'on trouvait pas de carburant pour
démarrer le groupe électrogène de
l'hôpital et donc mes proches ont
chercher du carburant partout pendant
trois jours j'étais entre la vie et la
mort j'avais mal
j'avais peur et je ne pouvais pas manger
c'était vraiment ma traversée du désert
et ma révélation au 21e siècle il est
inadmissible que des gens meurent à
cause du manque d'électricité
la vie est une étincelle que
l'électricité peut préserver c'est entre
entre cet entre deux que je me suis
alors décidé de devenir ingénieur en
électricité
j'ai poursuivi un cursus de génie
électrique jusqu'à l'obtention de mon
doctorat est toujours à la poursuite de
mon rêve de jeune fille j'ai créé une
société
il conçoit et installe des systèmes
solaires au congo j'ai appris que les ce
thème nous permettent d'obtenir des
solutions concrètes à des défis majeurs
ma passion est de trouver des solutions
durables et non polluantes aux problèmes
d'électricité pour que les gens
améliorent leur vie tout en luttant
contre le changement climatique comme la
voiture électrique par exemple alors de
nos jours une voiture électrique
contient une unique batterie qui est
d'ailleurs semblable à la batterie que
vous avez dans vos voitures la patrie
elle-même transforme l'énergie chimique
en énergie électrique et votre voiture
avance le seul problème c'est que pour
charger la batterie
il faut brancher la voiture à une prise
électrique pendant plusieurs heures
pendant lesquelles vous ne pouvez pas
utiliser la batterie et une fois que la
batterie chargée vous pouvez rouler
pendant un nombre limité de kilomètres
alors là commencent les calculs le
stress l'angoissé la peur de tomber en
panne sèche en rase campagne
ou plutôt en panne de jus dans ce cas
alors tout d'un coup vous voyez comment
une crainte une contrainte se transforme
en angoisse qui devient tout d'un coup
l'une des plus grandes barrières à
l'acceptation des voitures électriques
alors pour résoudre ce problème j'ai
créé une voiture électrique hybride
c'est-à-dire une voiture qui a deux
sources d'énergie une batterie et une
pile qui transforme un gaz en
électricité et ce gaz c'est l'hydrogène
alors l'hydrogène est l'élément le plus
abondant que nous avons dans l'univers
c'est à dire qui en a au delà de la
planète
c'est donc une source inépuisable si on
arrive à le capter dans la pile la
réaction chimique se passe de la manière
suivante l'hydrogène se combine avec
l'oxygène de l'air ambiant
pour former de l'eau et des électrons
les électrons créé le courant électrique
et la voiture avance il n'y a que de
l'eau qui est rejeté et donc vous voyez
qu'on obtient un système qui est non
polluant et qui permet à la voiture
d'avoir une plus grande autonomie
tout ce qu'il suffit de faire c'est de
charger la voiture en hydrogène de la
même manière qu'eux ont jeté charge une
voiture à la station d'essence alors là
je vous ai entendu vous dit sûrement
mais comment va-t-on créer de
l'hydrogène dans une station à hydrogène
alors pour cela j'ai créé un système qui
utilise des panneaux solaires pour
transformer la lumière du soleil en
électricité
cette électricité alimente une machine à
électrolyse qui va des composés l'eau en
hydrogène et oxygène et il suffit de
capter cet hydrogène dans une pompe qui
ressemble d'ailleurs à une pompe à
essence et de rouler avec la voiture et
maître de l'hydrogène pendant deux
minutes faire le plein d'hydrogène
pendant deux minutes pour continuer à
rouler
[Applaudissements]
alors lors de mon parcours
d'universitaires et de conférencière
j'ai assez rapidement remarqué que
j'étais souvent la seule la seule femme
noire africaine mère marié entrepreneurs
ingénieurs et professeurs d'après les
études l'atrice bonnaire et de
l'american society for engineering
éducation sur 27 mille cent soixante
douze professeurs en titularisation
conditionnelle d'ingénierie il n'y a que
142 femme noire cela représente 0,52
pour cent du corps professoral en
ingénierie aux états unis alors qu'il y
à 7% de femmes noires aux usa alors j'ai
réalisé qu'il était impératif pour notre
survie pour la survie des ducs et les
autres jeunes vers l'est ce thème afin
qu'eux aussi puissent pouvoir trouver
des solutions aux problèmes dont nous
faisons auxquels nous faisons face
j'ai trouvé que au delà de mon
expérience professionnelle et
personnelle
ça serait bien de diffuser les ce thème
autour de moi
c'est ainsi qu'avec un groupe d'amis
nous avons une association qui s'occupe
de la promotion des systèmes au congo
dans la diaspora et aux usa alors au
mois de juin
je suis allé à kinshasa pour faire un
atelier de robotique avec mon équipe et
nous avions travaillé en collaboration
avec une association qui s'occupe du
mentorat des jeunes filles venant des
familles démunies
il fallait que j'aille à kinshasa et que
j'apprenne à ces jeunes filles à
fabriquer
des robots à les programmer et à les
tester
alors je vous a vu je vous avoue qu'au
début les jeunes filles avaient peur et
elles m'ont dit qu'elles croyaient
qu'elle n'arriverait pas à le faire
on avait sélectionné une quinzaine de
filles et l'atelier a duré toute une
matinée on a divisé les filles en trois
groupes et ces jeunes filles aventure 12
et de 18 ans et chaque groupe travaille
à une station qui consistait à un
ordinateur et un kit alors au début
elles ont commencé à fabriquer les
robots et puis elles les ont programmées
et elles les ont testés mais au début de
l'atelier
elles m'ont dit qu'elle avait peur et ça
se voyait n'était pas très sûre d'elle
mais au fur et à mesure qu'on avance et
elle commence à se détendre et à sourire
et quand on arrivait vers la fin elles
ont vraiment éclaté de joie quand elles
ont vu que le robot marché comme prévu
alors vous auriez dû voir l'étincelle
dans les yeux de ces jeunes filles alors
quelques jours plus tard nous avons
organisé une cérémonie où madame denise
ni à kérou tshisekedi la première dame
de la république démocratique du congo
leur a donné un certificat pour avoir
participé à l'atelier vous auriez dû
voir la joie sur le visage de ces jeunes
filles et la fierté dans le regard de
leurs parents
l'année passée notre association a
offert six bourses d'études pour les
systèmes au congo et cette année nous
avons pu en offrir
63 ceci n'est qu'un début nous avons
encore beaucoup à faire pour allumer les
étincelles dans les yeux des jeunes
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]